striking testimony in the derrick shobin
murder trial a former police supervisor
testified
that officers should have ended
restraint of george floyd much sooner
than they did
two paramedics also took the witness
stand yesterday and one of them told the
jurors
he initially thought that george floyd
was already dead when chauvin still had
his knee on his neck
jamie yukis is following the trial in
minneapolis jamie a lot of people are
wondering what has derek shoving been
thinking and reacting to what has been
very damning testimony against him this
week
what's his demeanor like in the
courtroom so far
well this is what we know gail at times
when chauvin hears himself on tape he
starts noticeably tapping his feet and
taking notes
he seems agitated we still don't know
whether or not he will take the stand
though
george floyd's girlfriend of three years
did testify not only to tell us more
about the man floyd was
but also to preempt one of the defense's
central arguments
a warning the images and video you're
about to see are disturbing but has this
great
deep southern voice raspy
and he's like sis you okay sis
and i wasn't okay
courtney ross george floyd's girlfriend
described how the two met
at the shelter where floyd worked as a
security guard
he said um
can i pray with you when i felt alone in
this
lobby it was so sweet
she also talked about her and floyd's
struggles with opioid addiction
we both suffered from chronic pain
mine was in my neck and his was in his
back we got addicted
and and tried really hard
to break that addiction
many times a big part of the defense's
strategy
centers around floyd's addiction
claiming that it was largely responsible
for his death
paramedics derrick smith and seth
bravendier responded to the scene
i assumed that there was potentially
some struggle still because
they were still on top of them body
camera video shows smith
checking floyd's vitals while derrick
chauvin still had his knee on floyd's
neck
what did his condition appear to be to
you
overall in late terms i thought he was
dead
jurors also saw new body camera video of
paramedics working frantically to save
floyd's life
also on the stand now retired
minneapolis police sergeant david
plueger
that day called 911
about a possible incident because he was
the supervisor at the time
retired sergeant dave plueger called
chauvin and eventually made it to the
scene
did he mention anything about putting
his knee on mr floyd's neck or back
no and is the placement of a knee
on a subject's neck a use of force
yes because floyd died the case was sent
up the chain of command
and plugger was not responsible for a
full review of the incident
the defense argued that plugger should
not answer certain questions because he
had not reviewed
all the evidence after an extensive back
and forth between prosecutors and the
defense
the judge allowed pluger to answer this
question do you
have an opinion as to when the restraint
of mr floyd
should have ended in this encounter yes
what is it
when mr floyd is no longer offering up
any resistance to the officers that
could have
entered the restraint we spoke to a
legal expert who told us the defense
could try to file a motion for a
mistrial because the judge allowed the
sergeant to provide
what sounded like expert testimony even
though he was not
a use of force expert meanwhile the
judge told the jurors to expect a short
day today
tony all right jamie thank you very much